they are really not trying to let
anybody in the united states because
what even is this
i've been an american citizen for my
whole life and i'm about to take the
american u.s citizenship test i do not
think that this test is going to be easy
but you know what i'm going to do i'm
going to try my best
first question who elects members of the
house of memphis
all the people of their state citizens
from their district or the electoral
college
question one coming in hot why are you
guys doing this to me
the electoral college okay it's not the
electoral college people in the state
have to vote
for the people in the representative oh
we're gonna say all the people of their
state final answer
representatives they represent your
whole state so we're going with
all of the people from that state i'm
just going to go with b
citizens from their district because
this is
u.s citizenship test so i feel like
that's what's making most sense to me
i believe it's just the citizens from
their district but i don't know if
electoral
peop you know what i'm going to go with
b citizens from their dis we're going
with b
we're going with b i'm going to go with
citizens from their district
all right question number two what are
two cabinet level positions
a vice president and secretary of road
works
that sounds fake b secretary of state
and the attorney general
or c secretary of treasury and secretary
of international
affairs y'all i don't know nothing about
cabinets the only thing that's in my
cabinets are towels or non-perishables
we're talking about cabinet members so
people that are getting picked by the
president
okay i don't think vice president is
considered cabinet because it's not
something that the president
appoints cabinet
you open a cabinet let's say secretary
of state and the attorney general
i'm just gonna go with that shelf
shelves are in cabinets
okay so i believe it's secretary of
state and the attorney general
we're going with c on this one a big c
so secretary of state and attorney
general
i feel good about that one the
federalist papers supported the passage
of the u.s constitution
name one of the writers is it a thomas
jefferson
b alexander hamilton or c george
washington
name one of the writers yo i just want
to be confident about one of these
answers
that's it that's all i want it can't be
hamilton i didn't see the musical
hamilton i knew i know everyone else saw
it but
that feels like they're throwing that in
there for millennials or people who
watch the musical
oh this is it's hamilton what am i
thinking there's a musical alexander
hamilton
sounds sounds good to me wasn't hamilton
the one that wrote all the time like he
was like
in cursive jefferson was known for
writing a bunch of stuff
so i'm gonna go with thomas jefferson a
final answer
i'm gonna go with george washington just
i don't know i feel like it's alexander
hamilton
because he wrote that musical oh they're
gonna come for me in the comments
who is the chief justice for united
states we have
clarence thomas sonia sotomayor
or john roberts i feel like i should
know this because
it's now um but
clarence thomas is the only name that
like rings a bell so i'm just gonna go
with clarence
a clarence thomas just because chief of
justice starts with a c
all right we're going with b sonya cause
we love a queen
i'm going with clarence thomas i'm gonna
go with clarence
i am pretty sure it's john roberts
because
i'm pretty sure i've heard his name when
speaking for the majority in a ruling or
something
last question okay what is the rule of
law
is it a everyone must follow the law b
leaders do not have to follow the law
or see the government is above the law
look i may be dumb but i'm not this dumb
it's a everyone must follow along
right
so i definitely have more of an
appreciation for the
immigrants who have to take this test
i'm just happy
that i was born in the united states i
really think your average american is
going to have a really hard time taking
this test
and it just goes to show that a lot of
us americans really do take our
citizenship for granted
i understand that it's important because
we want the people that come into the
united states
to understand the history of our land
and whatnot
but like damn it's definitely some niche
political stuff going on in that test i
don't care what you all say in the
comments i'm not that dumb
this is hard i was not prepared if you
give me a week
to study this material i would have
passed
[Music]
you